a search team hold up what they believe
to be parts of the missing shrew ajaya
air flight
sj-182 metal objects entwined with
cables
found in the sea near to where the plane
disappeared
officials still have little to go on but
on this basis they fear the worst
as do many of the relatives of those on
board this man already
overcome with grief was expecting to
meet his daughter off the flight
but says he'll never see her again
[Music]
62 people were on board the plane that
took off from jakarta airport where
loved ones
now face an agonising weight for
information
the plane was bound for the city of
pontianak but just four minutes into its
journey
contact was lost the aircraft plunging
ten thousand feet
in fewer than sixty seconds its flight
path apparently
ending just off the coast
we are coordinating with the meteorology
climatology and geophysical agency
to find out what the weather conditions
were like at that time
there were 50 passengers and 12 crew
members on board
among them seven children and three
babies
search and rescue teams have been
dispatched to where they believe the
plane went down
but nightfall has hampered the operation
the aircraft was a boeing 737-500 which
first flew in 1994.
the airline doesn't believe it had any
problems
based on the information i have the
plane was in good condition when it was
flown from pontianak
and this was the second route back to
pontianak there shouldn't have been
any problem and the maintenance report
was also fine
but it's now all but certain that
something did go
seriously wrong and it's hoped this will
help determine
exactly what iva bennett sky news